well brian with that tense situation in
kabul some families here in the u.s are
struggling to get family members
overseas out of the country now that
includes rakai yosuzai he has families
stuck in the capital city who has been
trying to escape for days they've made
several attempts to get to the airport
with no luck he said communication has
been spotty and he hasn't had any
contact with his family since yesterday
morning he said he's worried about what
will happen from here and has a simple
plea
it's gonna get a lot worse
a lot of innocent
people gonna die regardless of the gen
regardless of the background
that
we need to pray
for the peace
for the world
we need to pray for the humanities
it's being destroyed
he says despite the unthinkable
situation his family was staying
positive about their escape though
they've experienced nothing but violence
and brutality from taliban soldiers he's
now working with our state senators
representatives and even the american
afghan council to try and rescue them he
says there needs to be strategy built so
so stranded americans and allies aren't
left behind in the future